er war damals lukas meine lieben freunde
es ist mal wieder soweit der von
schüssen zu tage der kompletten woche
ist zurück von einer habe ich euch heute
hier am dienstag herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen episode direkt mit den
besten tipp der woche die fresse du
laufen kommen wir nun aber wirklich zu
den tick tock sich diese woche wieder
für uns heraus gesucht habe und zwar
zuallererst zu einer person die komische
deutsche redewendungen auf englisch
übersetzt
horst faces.com wir uns in der fbs
mensch will ich mixe los ganz ehrlich
gerade pepper groß beide ab
[Musik]
ja der ihr seid die lightning challenge
ein wenig zu ernst genommen
machen wir jetzt allerdings direkt
weiter mit dem nächsten tor video worum
es dabei geht worum wie was war sprachen
lernen das nächste user zeigt uns auf
jeden fall einen vergleich zwischen ihm
wie viel macht und seiner mutter wie sie
eiswürfel macht auf also viel spaß beim
lesen als wenn hier irgendjemand spaß
hat
[Musik]
war das bei euch früher auch so ich weiß
ja dass es bei uns in der familie immer
so war dass jeder beim mittagessen
irgendwie mit helfen sollte wenn er denn
zu hause war und dann sollte ich mal den
quark machen also zum nachtisch hat man
mal wieso immer obstsalat mit quark und
wenn man das immer so telefonieren noch
nebenbei ich mache hier fernsehen gucke
ich noch mal eine show und dann schreibe
ich auch gerade ein bulli von buch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mein lieber user bekommst von mir den
ticketpreis der woche also schaut mal
auf tickt doch bei dem user dabei
unterstrich jacob vorbei und lasst sie
im rahmen ihres amtes baby
ja das war ja schon
aktiv gut aber ich
das hundertprozentig besser
[Musik]
hallo
doch ein bisschen zu mcdonalds und von
den paar leckere burger hättest du
vielleicht glauben dass ein paar leckere
bringen
am renault so komisch ich war jetzt
nicht warum ich komisch rede sondern
darum hab ich jetzt in meiner
hosentasche zudem tik tok muss ich ganz
ehrlich wieder sagen das ist
hundertprozentig die wahrheit ist und
ich glaube jeder von euch hat er auch in
seiner schulklasse oder in der stufe
mindestens eine person die auch so drauf
war so von wegen sie kommt da nicht
irgendwie klasse rein und sagt so 'oh
mein gott' leute wir hatten hausaufgaben
auf kann einer von euch mal die
vielleicht geben ich habe die vergessen
zu machen sondern leute haben auch die
freilich noch einer von euch gemacht
werden
[Musik]
haben wir uns beruhigt die nächste
person hat ihrer oma die lyrics von dem
lied roxanne gezeigt und sie sollte die
lyrics vorsingen programm
[Musik]
ja
fast so gut wie das original kommen
jetzt allerdings zu einer weiteren
person die das handy von dem sohn
gegeben bekommen getan und die sollte
auf jeden fall dieses artig pop video
einer tatana absprechen
ja
herzlich willkommen wir heute als er mir
ist gerade etwas aufgefallen und zwar
bei einem freund von mir dass fahrer das
klingt richtig das war die mario musik
oder was der mega krank was aber auch
mega krank ist ist das nächste tor video
new york
[Musik]
der typ nicht schon im jahr 2070 udo i
ich weiß dass wir so ein ähnliches video
schon mal in einer vorherigen folgetag
schulfrei hatten aber ich fand es
einfach mega mega lustig und das ist
doch einfach wirklich wieder die
wahrheit so ich denke mein verlose ich
telefonieren mit meiner mutter wenn ich
in los angeles bin das ist so ca die
weiteste entfernung die man von
deutschland weg sein kann und es ist so
alles perfekt synchronen diese news
leute die das von millionen leuten im
fernsehen ausstrahlen die kriegen sie
nicht geschissen übrigen sorry dass hier
die ganze zeit das ist ich hab' ich habe
vorhin
wie kommt man auf so was aber gut machen
wir weiter mit dem nächsten take your
video h willst du die rechte ich kenne
dich
ja also ich bin lucassen foto mache ich
bin ein riesen fan von dir er von mir
aus kann's los geht's
oh mein gott du siehst so gut aus
ja
dies versteht dann schreibt zwar gerne
in die kommentare
die nächste person auf twitter kommt auf
jeden fall zu spät in seinen
schulunterricht und hat die beste
entschuldigung beziehungsweise
begründung aller zeiten
dankeschön zufrieden mein bus auf einen
blick ist
ja also das nächste mal wenn ich
irgendwo zu spät mit sage ich auch
einfach danke dass ich zufrieden mein
bus hat meine bahn gegessen
willst du am nächsten tag wird
dargestellt wie lehrer klassenarbeiten
beziehungsweise tests zurückgeben und
dabei immer ihre finger ablecken und
dann die teile aus teilen also die die
ihnen nicht die teil aus haushalten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was ist das denn für eine halbe stunde
zieht sich ja eine zentrale aus den
80ern com gehört
[Musik]
ich dachte das wort nicht erreicht
ja es ist weg aber es ist trotzdem
witzig
[Musik]
gerade bereits gesehen habe war das ein
tutorial indem man einen luftballon mit
wasser füllen muss da kann man da
einfach ein gesicht aufmalen und dann
durch das draufkleben von so tesa
streifen kann man dann ein loch genau
die mitte machen und genau da spritzt
das wasser raus das hat jetzt eine
person nach gemacht hat es nicht so gut
geklappt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja never trust tik tok tutorial
machen wir weiter mit einer person die
die deutsche sprache gerade lernt und
ja so die schwierigkeit der deutschen
sprache in einem video zusammengefasst
einfach der dass die schule
ich bin ihnen die schule hsg in der
schule ja ich weiß
ich glaube es wieder 1000 mal im
heutigen video machen wir jedoch weiter
mit einer person die er mit seinem
kollegen in der bahn sitzt und bei
seinem kumpel mit seinem bier auf seinen
wir zeigen dass man das jetzt versteht
also ich glaube alle die schon mal bier
getrunken haben kennen diesen prank also
schaut einfach selbst ja das war
ekelhaft was auch ekelhaft ist in einer
gewissen form ist das nächste tik tok
video und zwar kennt ihr alle diese
personen die seine augen so rausziehen
kann mehr oder weniger da habe ich ja
vor einigen wochen schon mal in folge
ticket user darauf reagiert und diese
person trifft jetzt auf eine person die
seinen kiefer nach vorne schaut einfach
selbst
gießen rw
ja ich finds halt echt mal bemerkenswert
zu sehen welche talente verschiedene
leute haben mich meine jeder hat ja
irgend welche talente bei mir ist es
beispielsweise so dass sich das dass
wenn denn wenn wir also wenn im winter
dann irgendwie wenn es dann nicht wenn
ich haben wir verstehen die us kinos an
[Musik]
aber ich musste nach wie die leute
schreibt bitte in die kommentare
wie oft ich im heutigen video geklatscht
haben dazu müssen sie doch locker so 50
mal sein oder so meine lieben freunde an
der stelle wo ich das heute wieder jetzt
auch beenden wenn euch die heutige
episode tik tok user gefallen hat das
gerne einen daumen hoch unter dem video
hier das schaffen wir 40.000 likes das
war mega krasse mir zeigen dass sie die
serie über alles feiert ich hab's auch
tik tok laser luca hab dort heute auch
ein neues tik tok hochgeladen schreibt
mir euren tipp topp nahmen gern und in
die kommentare
dann schaue ich eventuell auch bei euch
vorbei und ihr kommt vielleicht in die
nächste folge tik tok tuesday nächsten
dienstag
[Musik]